we start with this breaking news from
Chicago where Empire actor Jesse
Smollett is in police custody after
turning himself in overnight he is
accused of faking I hate crime after his
story of being attacked by racists
fellow piece fell to pieces small that
has been charged with disorderly conduct
for filing a false police report which
is a felony in the state of Illinois
Jean Reynolds covered this investigation
since it began last month police in
Chicago say Smollett lied to them last
month when he claimed to mask Trump
supporters shouting racist and
homophobic slurs beat him up in the
middle of the night near his apartment
building
Smollett last spoke on national TV
before suspicions turned to him I still
want to believe with everything justice
to small let's acquaintances Ola an able
us and I wrote told investigators the
actor directed and paid them to stage
that attack Gloria Schmidt is their
attorney there was a point where this
story needed to be told and they manned
up and they said you know what we're
gonna correct this the men are
cooperating with police and have not
been charged
Schmidt says they testified before a
grand jury for about two and a half
hours Wednesday this surveillance video
obtained by CBS Chicago Station WBBM
shows the Osen dyra brothers buying a
red cap gloves and a ski mask the day
before Smollett claims he was assaulted
I think he should unload that conscience
and just come out until the American
people would actually have one small ATS
lawyers who have been joined by famed
criminal defense attorney Mark Geragos
vowed an aggressive defense in a
statement they said like any other
citizen mr. Smollett enjoys the
presumption of innocence particularly
when there has been an investigation
like this one where information both
true and false has been repeatedly
leaked
now if convicted jussie Smollett could
face a fine of $25,000 and up to three
years in prison viana Dean thank you